[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
عزل المراه الافغانيه يفجر مفارقه مثيره
بين طالبان وطهران وبريطانيا تتهم الحركه
باقصاء النساء
[موسيقى]
وعود امريكيه بمواصله دعم النساء
والمعتقلين في ايران ولا احتجاجات ترد على
قمع النظام بها هجمات
عاصفه القرن تحاصر الامريكيين وترفعوا
اعداد الضحايا وحكمه نيويورك تؤكد وانها
بعيده عن الانصار
بعد انتكاسات الموجعه تقرير يرسم صوره
خاتمه الاقتصاد العالم في 2023 ركود وتضخم
ومزيد من ارتفاع الاسعار
[موسيقى]
وصلتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
عندما يتعلق الامر بالحقوق والحريات تسير
للمراه الافغانيه في حقل انغام انغام
وضعتها حركه طالبان منذ توليها السلطه
لعزل المراه وهدم اي دور لها في المجتمع
وامام قرارات طالبان الاخيره بحرمان
المراه من التعليم والعمل لم يعد الامر
يتوقفوا على تمديدات او ضغوطات دوليه بل
يتطلب الامر بحسب ناشطين افغان تحركات
مدنيه من داخل افغانستان لكن رغم كل
التمديدات والتحذيرات تصمم الحركه على
انتهاكاتها ورفع سقف التحدي
[موسيقى]
وفي اطار التحركات الدوليه للضغط على
طالبان قال قبل قليل وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه
تسعى لاقصاء النساء من المجتمع عبر حظر
عملهم في المنظمات الدوليه فيما التقى
اليوم رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في
افغانستان مع وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه
طالبان وحثه هو على الغاء القرار المتعلق
بحضر عمل الافغانيات وفي بيان لبعثه الامم
المتحده اشار المبعوث الى ان الملايين
الافغان يحتاجون الى المساعدات الانسانيه
وتذليل العقبات لكن الطالبان لم ترد ولم
تعلق
من جانبها اعلنت منظمتاه الاغاثه كلشن ايد
واكشن ايد تعليق نشطهما في افغانستان بعد
ان امر طالبان بحضر عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه ما يرفع الاجمالي
الى ست منظمات اتخذت خطوه مماثره وحتى
منظمه كرستيشن ايد البريطانيه طالبا على
الغاء الحظر معربه عن اسفها لتعليق عملها
في افغانستان
في افغانستان تعليم النساء وعملهن ممنوع
بقوه قانون طالبان خطوه جرت على الحركه
انتقادات دوليه واسعه حتى من حكومات تمارس
انواع القمع والتسلط على النساء كالنظام
الايراني الجهود الدوليه والمطالب بالغاء
القرار متواصله القائم باعمال رئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده الى افغانستان حتى القائمه
باعمال وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان على
الغاء خطوه حظر عمل موظفه منظمه غير
الحكوميه بعثه الامم المتحده للمساعده في
افغانستان قالت في بيان ان ملايين الافغان
بحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه ومن الضروري
تذليل العقبه الموجوده وزاره الاقتصاد في
حكومه طالبان سبق ان حدثت جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه المحليه منها والاجنبيه بمنع
موظفيها من العمل حتى اشعار اخر
الاوامر لا تنطبق بشكل مباشر على الامم
المتحده لكن المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي
يشملها القرار تتولى تنفيذ الكثير من
برامج الامم المتحده ما يهدد بازمه اخرى
ستواجه النساء والاسرى الافغانيه لتضاف
الى كل الازمات التي يعاني منها الشعب
الافغاني بلال الوجديني العربيه
ووسط زحمه ردود الافعال المهدده بقرارات
طالبان كان لابد من التوقف عند موقف ايران
فهل المفارقه وزاره الخارجيه ايران علقت
على قرار منع طالبان النساء من التعليم
الجامعي واعرضت عن سفها وجاء الحديث
تحديدا على لسان المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني طبعا
المفارقه هنا ان ياتي تعليق كهذا من بلد
تقوم فيه سلطات نفسها بقمع النساء
والطالبات وخير مثال ما تقوم به السلطات
في هذه الاحتجاجات الان التي بدات شرارتها
بعد مقتل مهسا اميني على يد شرطه الاخلاق
الايراني
لكنه طالبان لم تتجاهل الامر فردت على
انتقادات النظام الايراني حيث نشر حساب
تويتر التابع لوزاره الخارجيه في طالبان
ان من الافضل لهم في اشاره الى النظام
الايراني اقناع النساء المحتجات في بلادهم
وان لا يحاولوا باسم التعاطف لفه النظر عن
مشاكلهم الداخليه الى بلدنا وفقا ما جاء
في التغريبه
[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن ايران وبنفس الزخم دخل
تحتجاجات ايران شهرها الرابع وسط استمرار
قمع النظام وتوسيع حمله اعتقالات وقد دع
المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
برايس الى الافراج غير المشروط عن جميع من
تم سجنهم في ايران بسبب ممارسه حرياتهم
بشكل سلمي حسب تعبيره واشاره رئيس في
تغريده على تويتر الى مسانده واشنطن
للنساء ايران بعد طرد طهران من لجنه
المراه في الامم المتحده في وقت سابق هذا
الشهر واضاف المتحدث الامريكي وان الكفاح
من اجل حصول النساء الايرانيات على حقوقهن
مستمر
هذا هو كشف تقرير صادر عن موقع متخصص في
شؤون الايرانيه عن ان المواقع الحكوميه
شهدت هجمات متعدده خلال الاشهر الماضيه من
قبل مخترقين ايرانيين يؤمنون بدورهم في
حمايه المتظاهرين المحتاجين على مقتل مساء
مكه
ايران لا تنحصر تداعيات الانتفاضه التي
اشعلها مقتل مساميني في شوارع والساحات
وحتى شرفات المنازل بل طالت العالم
الافتراضي الحكومي
تقرير صادر عن موقع متخصصا في الشؤون
الايرانيه اشار الى ان المواقع الحكوميه
الايرانيه شهدت خلال الاشهر الماضيه هجمات
سيبرانيه مختلفه في شكلها ومضمونها من
مخترقين ايرانيين يؤمنون بدورهم في حمايه
المتظاهرين المحتجين على وفاه ام السامين
هجمات سيبرانيه اريد بها بشكل اساسي
استهداف البنيه الالكترونيه للحكومه
الايرانيه
والتسبب باكبر قدر ممكن من الاضرار لتلك
المواقع ومن ابرز مجموعات القرصنه تلك
وعداله علي وباك دور وبلاك ريبورد
التقرير اوضح ايضا ان الهجمات تسببت
بخسائر اقتصاديه وعملياتيه منها ما نتج عن
هجوم فيروس ستوكسنت الذي طال البرنامج
النووي الايراني اضافه الى استهداف منظومه
توزيع الوقود والبنزي التي ادت الى خسائر
ماديه كبيره
وتعطل موقع بلديه طهران الذي يضم مئات
الخدمات والاف عمليات الدفع
كالمقابل تقول سلطات الايرانيه انها تعمل
على تطوير قدرتها الالكترونيه بشكل سريع
من خلال انشاء قاعده دفاعيه مدنيه تراقب
التهديدات وتوفر المعدات وتدعم البنيه
التحتيه والبرمجيات على مدار الساعه وفقا
لنوع التهديدات في محاوله منها لمواجهه
تلك الهجمات الالكترونيه التي تصاعدت في
الاونه الاخيره في وقت تؤكد فيه المؤشرات
على ان العالم الافتراضي سيكون ميدان حروب
المستقبل
رند الشيخ العربي
[موسيقى]
ونعود مشاهدينا الى ملفنا الاول حول
قرارات طالبان الاخيره ضد المراه
الافغانيه حول الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
حسنه جيلي وهي نائبه وزير شؤون المراه
السابقه السيد حسني اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه من العربيه في احدث المواقف
الدوليه وزير الخارجيه البريطاني طالب قبل
قليل الحركه الطالبان بالتراجع عن القرار
بشكل عاجل الى اي حد برايك الضغط الدولي
يمكن ان يغير شيئا
كان سرنجه
التي اخذتها طالبان وعلى حاله وعلى خلفيه
حاله الفرقه التي تعيشها فقد يكون هناك
حالا من الانقسام بين صفوف طالبان التي
تنميل معظمها الى الايديولوجيا المتطرفه
وقد يكون هذا امر لن يثني طالبان عن
التراجع عن قرار بشان تعليم المراه بما في
ذلك حضور الجامعه
كان هناك مظاهرات يعني على نطاق ضيق هي
تخش طبعا من القمع الكبير اللي حركه
طالبان احتجاجا على قرار منع الفتيات من
الالتحاق بالجماعات كذلك هل برايك يمكن ان
يتشكل ضغط داخلي كذلك احتجاجات ربما اوسع
نطاقا مثل ما حصل في ايران احتجاجا على
القرارات ضد النساء في افغانستان
هتندمي
الداخليه
وفي معظم المناطق التي تحكمها طالبان في
الجنوب وفي شرق افغانستان
واعتقد ان هذه الناحيه ايجابيه وقد تكون
نقطه اساسيه على الاطالبا توسعت حلقتها
فان طالبان سوف تاخذ الامر على محمل الجلد
المراه في الحكومه السابقه
برايك لماذا تتصرف طالبان على هذا النحو
هل هي تريد ان تستفز المجتمع الدولي حتى
يتعامل معها ام هي حقا يعني هي تريد ان
تطبق نظاما صارما همم يستبعد النساء من كل
شيء
ايوه الجو ده الليره
الفرضيه الثانيه لا اعتقد ان الامر قد
يكون بمثابه نقطه ضغط على الاسره الدوليه
كما كان الحال في السابق من قبل لطالبا
لكن هذا لا يبدو انه النقطه الاساسيه بل
هي سياسه مواجهه ضد النساء وهم يسعون
لتنفيذي سياسته القرن الماضي
وهناك اعداد كبيره
[موسيقى]
هم الذين يؤمنون بهذا الفكر المتشدد جدا
والمتطرف ضد المراه هل برايك يمكن التعويل
على الجناح الاخر همم المعتدل قليلا الذي
لا ينظر هذه النظره همم
على انه يمكن ان يغير في الوضع
[موسيقى]
المتطرفون الذين يملكون زمام الامور
والسلطه ولا ارى ان اي من هؤلاء في صفوف
الطالب ان يعدون من المعتدلين لانهم حتى
المعتدرين هم من الصامتين الذين لا
يتفوهون ولا يلبسون ببنت شفاء لدافع هناك
حاله من الاقسام لكن كل صفوف طالبان
نفس السياسه من الصعب التعويل عليهم
واعتباره اي منهم من المعتدللين
اخر سؤال لو سمحت همم سيد حسن كان اليوم
هناك سجال بين النظام الايراني وحكومه
الطالبان ايران التي انتقدت الاجراءات
الافغانيه ضد المراه وردت حكومه الطالبان
على ايران بان همم يعني بعد عدم التدخل في
شؤونها الداخليه كيف تعلقين على الانتقاد
الايراني
هابي ايران
لكن لا يوجد لهذه التعليقات اي صدقيه فان
النظام الايراني ليس بافضل حال من الواقع
في في افغانستان ويقوم بقمع المراه لكن
طالبا تحظى بدعم من باكستان
لكنها ايضا النظام في افغانستان الصحيح
شكرا جزيلا لك حسنى جليل انتي نائبه وزير
شؤون المراه الافغانيه سابقا كنت معنا من
واشنطن
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بعد اعترافته
العنصريه منفذ هجوم باريس نادم لانه لم
يقتل عددا اكبر من الا
[موسيقى]
كرم
مرحبا بكم من جديد مصطلحوا التفاوض بات
متداولا بشكل كبير في معجم الكبار
المسؤولين الروس الموضوع تجاوز التلميح
وبدا يدخل مرحله التاكيد في روسيا باتت
مستعده للتفاوض مع اوكرانيا وحلفائها حول
ايجاد حل للحرب في اوكرانيا او هكذا تقوله
في العلن اخر الاصوات المؤثره الملوحه
بالتفاوض وزير الخارجيه الروسي الذي صرح
ان الغرب سينتجه نحو التفاوض مع روسيا بعد
ما سيشهد ضعفا خطيرا في قدرته على توجيه
الاقتصاد العالم سردي الى ظروف اتهم في
مقابله مع عقدته وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
الغربه والولايات المتحده الى دفع دول
العالم لاتخذه موقف عدائي
كلامه وزير الخارجيه الروسيه تناغم كليا
مع التصريحات الاخيره للرئيس الروسيه
فلديمير بوتين كان بوتن قال ان بلاده
مستعده لتفاوض مع كل اطراف السرعه
الاوكراني بشان حلول مقبوله ووضع الكره في
ملعب كياب وحلفائها مشيرا الى ان موسكو لا
ترفض التفاوض لكن هم يرفضون على حد تعبيره
وعلى الطرف الاخر لما ترسل اوكرانيا اي
اشارات حول امكانيات اللجوء الى الحل
التفاضي بل وصلت ادانتها لموسكو حيث دعاه
اوكرانيا عن طريق بيان لوزاره الخارجيه
دول الاعضاء في الامم المتحده الى حرمان
روسيا من وضعها كعضو دائما في مجلس الامن
واستبعادها كليا من الامم المتحده
معنى من موسكو مراسلنا عبد الجواد الرشد
عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا في اي سياق الوضع
لافروف حتميه اجبار الغرب على الجلوس الى
طاوله التفاوض مع روسيا
مساء الخير صهيب حديث وزير الخارجيه
الروسي الشرقي الله ظروف حول ان الغرب
سيجلس الى طاوله الحوار شام ابي يستند الى
ثقتي موسكو بان العالم مقدم على مرحله
تعدد الاقطابروف طبعا صعد الموقف اليوم
وتطرق الى الدور السلبي للغرب في اداره
الملف الاوكراني او الملفات العالميه طبعا
لظروف تحدث
واكد ثقته بان الغرب يحاول طبعا هزيمه
والحاقه الهزيمه بموسكو في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وان واشنطن تقوم بالضغط على
الكثير من دول العالم
للانخراب داخل المنهج العقوبات او اتخاذ
سياسات سعيده اتجاه روسيا لكن طبعا على
الجانب الاخر صهيب نلاحظ بان بعض السياسيه
في البلاد التي ترى في ان جميع الاطراف
التي تذهب وتبحث عن الجلوس طاوله
المفاوضات ليس لديها اي ثقه بوجود ارضيه
يمكن ان من عليها كافه الاطراف لايجاد حل
لهذا الموضوع
يبدو اننا سنتحدث عن نفس الشيء نتحدث عن
الخبر العاجل عن الكرملين الذي قال ردا
على مقترح اوكرانيا للسلام عبد الجواد
روسيا لا تتبع شروط احد يقول الكريم وهو
يتناغم كذلك ما قاله كذلك بان روسيا لن
تنسحب من اي من المناطق التي سيطرت عليها
في همم اوكرانيا وبالتالي عن اي تفاوض
تفاوض على ماذا هنا من قبل روسيا الذي يتم
الحديث عن وثارتها من قبل بوتين والان من
طرف لاظروف
القراءه السياسيه لهذا الموقف سهيب في
البلاد تتحدث عن ان رغم يعني اقرار جميع
الاطراف بضروره الجلوس لطوله المفاوضات
الا ان مواقف واشنطن او الغرب ومواقف كيف
تختلف كليا عن مواقف موسكو خاصه ان يعني
مع وجود انعدام الثقه بين الطرفين وموسكو
لم تعد تخفي لم تعد تخفي انعدام ثقتها
بالغرب خاصه مع تصريحات المستشاره
الالمانيه السابقه انجيلا ميركل التي قالت
بان اتفاقيات ميسك عام 2014 كانت فقط يعني
لتمهيد الطريق لكيف لاعاده ترتيب اوراقها
والتسلح يعني عسكريا ضد روسيا لذلك طبعا
كل المقترحات لايجاد حل لجلوس طاولت
المفاوضات يعني نلاحظ لديها رفض من العديد
من الاراء السياسيه في البلاد روما حديث
قاده البلاد الكرملين والخارجيه عن هذا
الموضوع صحيح عبد الجواد الرشد من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
نبقى مع الحرب الاوكرانيه ولكن ميدانيا
هذه المره وتحديدا في باخبط حيث تتواصل
عمليه القسط المتبادل بين القوه
الاوكرانيه والروسيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من اوكرانيا نذهب الان الى فرنسا صوت
الغضب يصدح في مختلف ارجاء باريس الجاليه
الكرديه في العاصمه الفرنسيه تواصل
التمديد بهجوم الدائره الذي اودى بحياه
ثلاثه اكراد قتلا بالرصاص لكنها تتجنب
اشعال فتى للعنف متظاهروا الجاليه الكرديه
في باريس قرروا انهاء مسيره لهم تنديدا
لهجوم باريس انهوها بشكل مبكر تجنبا لاي
اعمال شغب الجلسه الاولى من محاكمه المتهم
صنعت الاحداث بشكل موازن منفذ الهجوم ادلب
اعترافات المثيره كشفت نزعته العنصريه
وزاره العدل اعلنت عن جزء من اعترافاته
حيث اكد انه يشعر برغبه في قتل مهاجرين
اجانب وذلك منذ تعرض منزله للسطو في عام
المتهم اعترف ايضا انه ناقم على كل
المهاجرين معبرا عن شعوره بالغضب تجاه
الاكراد لانهم اثروا مقاتلين اثناء
محاربتهم داعش بدلا من تصفيتهم على حد
تعبره اللافت مشاهدينا انه ابدى ندمه على
انه لم يقتل عددا اكبر
وبعد اعترافاته العنصريه هذه تم اصدار
لائحه الاتهام بحق المتهم بقتل الاكراد
حيث اوضح مصدر قضائي ان منافذ هجوم باريس
وهو سائق قطار متقاعد يحمل الجنسيه
الفرنسيه وجه له قاضي التحقيق تهامه القتل
ومحاوله القتل على اساس العرق او الاثنين
او البلد او الدين مفضلا او فضلا عن
اتهامه بالحصول على اسلحه وحيازتها دون
رخصه
[موسيقى]
من فرنسا الى امريكا
صعبه
ولايه امريكيه وقال دائره الارصاد الجويه
الامريكيه ان حوالي 60% من سكان الولايات
المتحده تلقوا تحذيرات متعلقه بالعاصفه
كما تجاوز مجموع الرحلات الجويه المغاث
منذ بدايه العاصفه احد عشر الف رحله وفقا
لموقع التتبع الجوي
[موسيقى]
نيورك تاخذه المعركه الاصعب الان مع
الثلوج وتحديد المدينه
عن الحصان
اه اتفاجا طيب
نعلم انه سيكون هناك المزيد من الارقام
الخاصه بالضحايا والتي سيتم الكشف عنها
بمجرد تاكيدها فعليا
[موسيقى]
معنى مراسلنا في واشنط حسين طرد الان حسين
اهلا بك معنا
كما استمعنا قبل قليل حاكمت نيويورك قالت
انها عاصفه القرن المميته لم تنتهي بعد
ماذا تقول الاحوال الجويه توقعات ماذا
تقول
[تصفيق]
حسين هل تسمعني
المميته لم تنتهي بعد الارصاد الجويه ماذا
تتوقع في الولايات المتحده خاصه في
الولايات المتاثره بالعاصفه
صهيب بالفعل ما زال تاثير هذه العاصفه
مستمر وهذا ما تحذر منه
السلطات الامريكيه ولكن في نفس الوقت
خدمه الارصاد الجويه تقول بان الاحوال
بشكل عام ستتحسن خلال الايام القادمه وحتى
نهايه الاسبوع ولكن تاثيرات ذلك حتى الان
هي تاثيرات خطيره هناك تجمد للطرقات هناك
انزلاقات عدم وضوح في الرؤيا في العديد من
الاماكن كما انه هناك تداعيات همم
اقتصاديه وبشريه على مختلف اذا تحدثنا
مثلا على موضوع الطيران هناك اليوم كان
همم كان هناك الغالي ثلاثه الاف رحله
وتاجيل او تاخير لحوالي همم خمسه الاف
رحله الكره تتحدث على الصعيد الوطني او
الدولي الدخول والخروج من المملكه المتحده
تاثير هذه ال- ال- هذا الانفجار القطبي
كما يوصف وصل حتى الى اماكن هي اماكن
دافئه مثلا
وغيرها هناك تحضيرات هناك 10 مليون شخص
يعيش في ظل تحضيرات من التجميد هذه كلها
هي تاثيرات هي لن تنتهي بين ليله وضحاها
هي ستمتد الى خلال الايام المقبله ولكن
طبعا من المفارقه اننا نتحدث عن تحسن
بدرجات الحراره ولكن نعني بذلك اننا
سننتقل من 16 تحت السفر الى صفر الان حيث
اقف انا درجه الحراره واحد همم ولكن ستبدا
بالهبوط الى ان تصل الى نقل السته مع
منتصف الليل صراعات الصباح الاولى ان هي
موجه برد قارصه بطبيعه الحال هذه المنطقه
تعرف هذا درجات منخفضه خلال العام ولكن
قوه هذه هذه المره انها كانت مسحوبه برياح
عاديه ادت ايضا الى الى تفاقم الازمه والى
حدوث وفيات كثيره في مختلفه المناطق
الامريكيه ولكن بالطبع
همم
كان في غرب ولايه نيويورك وما جاورها
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك حسين الطود مباشره من
واشنطن
العاصفه الثلجيه هذه هو ما رافقها من
انخفاض شديد في درجات الحراره جمد كل شيء
تقريبا حتى صنابير المياه شاهدوا
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل نعود في اخبار الساعه ونتابع
اردوغان يلوح بتصعيد جديده في الشمال
السوري
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
في شمال السوريين اردوغان قال ان بلادهم
مصره على مكافحه ما وصفها بتنظمات
المصالحه على حدودها مع سوريا بعمق 30 كلم
واضاف اردوغان ان تركيا تتخذ خطوه جديده
للقضاء بشكل تام على تهديدات التي تشكل
وتنظمات في سوريا على تركيا كما اعلن رئيس
تركيا عن تحدي مئات العناصر المصالحه في
عمليات العسكريه داخل وخارج حدود بلاده
[موسيقى]
222 لم يكن عامل انتعاش الاقتصاديه بينما
لا يزال اقتصاد العالم يتعافى من تبعات
جائعات كورونا حيث تلقى انتكاسات موجعه
دفعت الى الهبوط و رسمت صوره قاتمه لما هو
قادم فقبل نحو شهر لقى صندوق النقد الدولي
ناقوس الخطر مرجحا ان تتفاقم الازمه
الاقتصاديه في ظل الاستمرار التضخم
المرتفع والخلل في الامدادات وانعدام
الامن الغذائي الناجمي عن حرب اوكرانيا
وخفض الصندوق التوقعاته للنمو العالمي
لعام
2023,09 الى 2.7
هذه توقعات عزازها تقرير او صدر اليوم عن
مركز ابحاث الاقتصاد والاعمال
خطر الركود في العام المقبل التقرير
السنوي للمركز رسم صوره قاتمه الاقتصاد
العالم في ظل المعركه التي يخوضها صناعه
السياسه خصوصا ضد ارتفاع الاسعار في هذه
المعركه ضد التضخم لم تنتصر بعد ببساطه
لانها تكلفه خفض التضخم الى مستويات
مقبوله تعني نمو اضعف متوقعا لعدد من
السنوات القادمه كل هذه توقعات المتشائمه
مشاهدات تعني اننا امام مع من صعب سيؤثر
بشكل مباشر على جيوب المواطنين وحياتهم
اليوم
[موسيقى]
معنا في اخبار الساعه هذه الليله في
الاستديو الاستاذ فؤاد صدقي الاستشاري في
التخطيط المالي يوسف فؤاد اهلا بك كل عام
وانت بخير رغم هذه التقارير يعني
المتشائمه بخصوص الوضع الاقتصادي والمالي
في العام المقبل كل هذه المؤشرات يعني كيف
ستؤثر علينا في العالم العربي المواطنين
في العالم العربي كيف ستؤثر عليهم كل هذه
التقارير المتشائمه اقتصاديه
كلها بتقول ان سنه 2023 هتكون سنه صعبه
حتى لو اغلب الناس حاسه 2022 كانت سنه
صعبه المؤشرات كلها بتقول ان لسه في اصعب
من كده او على الاقل ما فيش تحسن ملحوظ
حتى هذه اللحظه المشكله بس في ان التضخم
هيزيد وفي ان الاسعار هتزيد وطبعا اجاباتا
على سؤالك الاحساس اللي المواطن هيحس بيه
هو ارتفاع الاسعار
وانخفاض القوه الشرقيه اللي في فلوس
المواطنين ال- المشكله الاكبر بالنسبه لي
هي ان المشكله
بمعنى انه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
مستمره فطول ما احنا مش عارفين نحدد
بالضبط امتى ممكن نتوقع انتهاء المشكله دي
فبالتالي انا اتوقع زي اغلب التقارير اللي
بنقراها وبنشوفها ان سنه 2023 تكون سنه
صعبه من حيث القوه الشرائيه الفلوس
بارتفاع اكثر
وارتفاع في الاسعار بالضبط
ومختص في الامور الماليه كيف الان بحكمه
كيف علينا ان نتصرف ماليا في عام 2023 طيب
انا هادي مثلا بسيط دائما باستخدمه في في
النطاق ده همم المثل ده حصل سنه 1987 شركه
من اكبر شركات الطيران في العالم وهي
امريكان ايرلاينز في الوقت ده همم عن طريق
حاجه بسيطه جدا عملتها قدرت انها تخفض من
تكاليفها اكثر من 40 الف دولار سنويا همم
السر في حاجه اسمها سر الزتونه همم صدق او
لا تصدق امريكا عن طريق انها تشيل قطعه
زيتون واحده من وجبات الفرس في الطيران
بتاعتها انها تخفض اكثر من 40,000$ من
تكاليفها الثانويه نعم لو المواطن العادي
قدر ان هو يعمل كده ويطبق الموضوع ده في
حياته ده هينتج عنه همم مش انت عايشه ولكن
على الاقل هيقدر يسيطر على التضخم اللي
حاصل على فلوسه لان التضخم اللي حاصل
دلوقتي في العالم حوالي في امريكا مثلا
بنتكلم في 80% في بعض الدول العربيه يوصل
لاكثر من 18% في بند معين من مصاريف
الاشخاص احنا بنقول عليه في مصر انا مش
عارف الفلوس دي راحت فين راحت فين احنا
بنصرف فلوس بالذات في الحاجات اللي ما
بناخدش بالنا ان احنا بنصرف فيها ودائما
بيكون الحاجات الصغيره اللي بنصرف فيها
بطريقه مستمره وبصفه دوريه طيب في مثال
الامريكان لايف هو مثال ده جدا المثال همم
الزيتون التي يستغنت عنها في همم درجات
همم الدرجه الاولى وبالتالي خفض من نفقات
الشركه مضبوط بالنسبه لنا المواطنين
العاديين بالنسبه ما هي الزيتونه بالنسبه
يمكن الاستغناء عن صحيح الزيتون اللي احنا
ممكن نستغنى عنها هي الحاجات اللي احنا
بنصرف فيها من غير ما ناخذ بالنا زي زي
المصريات والحاجات اللي بنصرفها فدوريه
وبصفه مستمره بارقام بسيطه جدا كل شهر زي
كوبايه القهوه اللي انا بشربها كل يوم
خارج البيت او الاكل بره البيت او في ناس
بتصرف على التدخين او اللي احنا بنسميها
النسريات لو قدرنا ان احنا نركز مع
المصاريف دي ونشوف احنا كل شهر وكل اسبوع
وكل يوم بنصرف حاجات صغيره جدا في قد ايه
ونضربها في الاسبوع وفي الشهر وفي السنه
في اخر السنه الرقم اللي هيتوفر لنا ممكن
يكون اكثر
لابد من الرابطه الحزام يعني
همم في بعض المؤشرات الايجابيه مثلا همم
التضخم في امريكا انخفض في شهر نوفمبر الى
5.5 هو كان 6.1% في همم اكتوبر هل هذا
مؤشر ايجابي يمكن ان نتفائل انه التضخم
منخفض قليلا في امريكا تمام
ده بيدينا مؤشر عن ان نسبه التضخم حصل
عليها نوع من التحجيم ولكن ما وصلتش
للمستويات المطلوبه لان المستويات
المطلوبه اغلب الحكمات بتبقى عايزه يحصل
تضخم في العالم لان ده بيس في الاقتصاد
وبيساعد في النمو لكن التضخم ده بيكون
بالنسبه معقوله جدا بتكون من واحد ل 3%
يعني نقدر نقول 2% لكن لو التضخم زاد عن
كده ساعتها ده ما بيبقاش مؤشر كويس كون
انت بتضخم انخفض من النسبه اللي كان عليها
اللي النسبه قل ده مؤشر على تحكيم التضخم
مش انتهائه فطبعا ده مؤشر كويس لكن لسه
هياخذ شويه وقت لحد ما النسبه توصل للنسبه
المطلوبه نعم طيب همم الحديث معك شيء
الحقيقه ولكن نعود الى مساله ال- ال-
التخطيط المالي كذلك همم هناك الان بعض
الخدمات الاستشاريه همم من شركات ربما
تقترح على الافراد تخطيط المالي ل همم
حياتهم ال- الماليه تنصح بهذا هل هذا شيء
ممكن يكون مفيد ولا هو همم بعزاء الفلوس
لا هو اكيد مش بعزقت فلوس لانه بمنتهى
البساطه عشان المواطن العادي يفهم انت لما
بتتعب بتروح للدكتور لو عايز تبني بيت
بتروح للمهندس انت لو عايز تخطط لحياتك
ماليا لازم تروح لاستشاري التخطيط المالي
ده بيكون شخص باريس ويقدر يقول لك تصرف في
ايه وما تصرفش في ايه وتحاولش ازاي وازاي
تستثمر فلوسك بدون التوجيهات دي انت ممكن
تكون بتتصرف غلط وانت مش عارف فطبعا بنصح
جدا بالتوجه اللي مثل هذا هؤلاء الاشخاص
لان بيكون عندهم خبره والضرايه اللي توجهك
في الطريق الصحيح شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
فؤاد صدقي ان تستشاري تخطيطا الملك كنت
معنا هنا في الاستديو شكرا جزيلا شكرا
[موسيقى]
الان مع وقفتنا اليوميه مع ابرازي احداثي
شهر يوليو من هذا العالم
[تصفيق]
ممكن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السابعه يعني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
13 مليون برميل يوميا وبعد ذلك لن يكون
لدى المملكه اضافيه لزياده الانتاج وندعوا
ايران باعتبارها دوله يربطنا بشعبها روابط
دينيه وثقافيه الى التعاون مع دول منطقه
لتكون جزء من هذه الرؤيا والتعاون مع
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
[موسيقى]
من حقوق ولا القريات صدور يحميها
[تصفيق]
نمر
[موسيقى]
وصلنا الى نهايه اخبار الساعه لهذا المساء
اليكم الان تذكرهم ابرز العناوين
عزل المراه
مثيره بين الطالبان وطهران وبريطانيا
باقصاء النساء
والمعتقلين في ايران والاحتجاجات ترد على
قمع النظام بهجمات صبرا
عاصفه القرن تحاصر الامريكيين وترفع اعداد
ضحايا وحاكمه نيويورك تؤكد انها بعيده عن
الانحسار
بعد انتكاسات الموجعه تقرير يرسم صوره
خاتمه لاقتصاد العالم في 2023 ركود وتضخم
ومزيد من ارتفاع الاسعار
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء